[Music]
today's show is about connecting our
kids when they're going back to school
when they're disconnected in our home
and we also talk to an awesome daughter
and sister
whose parents believe we are in end
times and it's the end of the world and
we know it and they don't feel fine stay
tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dolone's show we're so glad you're
here so glad you're hanging out with us
whether we are piping into your
headphones
or you're driving along with your family
every time i hear somebody say yeah me
and my kids are i was like wow man cool
rock on dude however you're listening to
the show we're so glad you're with us
talking about mental health
relationships taking real calls from
real people
and we've got some uh
good stuff on today's show i'm glad
you're here but before we get rolling
kelly
dude you're a nascar driver down down
the old uh highways what happened so i
was driving in this morning in my
minivan and the
cool mom alert exactly and there was a
big huge truck in front of me like a big
ford dually and he had he was he was
swerving i don't know if he was on his
phone or what but he was swerving around
and i couldn't get around him because of
some semis and all of a sudden he had
this big amazon box in the back of his
truck and it flew off and was coming
toward my windshield
and i was able to swerve because i
didn't know what was it was in the box
like a human head or like cocaine
sorry that's my seven reference what's
in the box step one cut you did not cut
a hole okay so
well i was able to swerve thank goodness
somebody was next to me and then but the
box hit the corner of my car and it just
exploded it just had like packing
material in it oh it's not body parts or
cash or something no not that i couldn't
see anything but i had to pull over and
some guy pulled over on the side of the
road and make sure my car was okay but
he just kept driving
he had places to go kelly yeah i had a
lot of words none which i can share here
and there's no kids in the car no no
well dude i'm glad you're okay thank you
my heart is still pounding it was that's
me that's the effect i have on people
no no it usually slows down that's
usually just slows down until it's
almost dead
i've heard this show is a great
meditation app for people to go to sleep
to um the uh
most important here like i'm glad you're
okay and blah blah but the minivan are
we good it's good
thankfully because it's like the new one
so um yeah but it's all good i mean
never said fine because it was just the
box and packing material but i just had
visions of like what's in this box
that's coming through my windshield here
in a minute
into my head
but it lasts james how was your drive to
work this morning i mean by comparison
it was lovely
i just think it's great that kelly was
like one minute late for for show call
time here because the boxing car so yeah
from now on if anybody's late she's
going to be like oh what happened did a
box hit your car this morning yesterday
did you
and i'm glad that you managed to blame
ford and amazon and a driver who's
probably texting and driving like it's
awesome i was thinking we could come up
with some way cooler stories about what
this idiotic guy was doing in there
well when i passed him um because i when
i finally
i pulled over and everything and then he
was at the same exit i was um
and i didn't make any rude hand gestures
i would like you to know i like you rage
caught up with him i love it well we
were at the same stoplight and he but he
went the other direction i mean he was
just sitting there at the wheel but i he
had no idea yeah people were passing him
because he was swerving before that and
flipping him off and all sorts of things
but he was just oblivious i guess he did
not know what was coming for him which
was an angry kelly in a minivan if i
hadn't had to be here and i was like
right you know about to be late
that's like ancient predatory it is
just this
inside yeah
you're like where did that come from
oh i know where it comes from yeah i see
it every day staring at me through the
glass
it's awesome
well i'm glad you're okay dude it's
awesome all right let's go to uh lynn in
eugene oregon good morning lynn how are
you
hi i'm good
thanks awesome what's up man how can i
help
um
well i appreciate the banter this
morning too it helped my heart kind of
calm down
clearly you've listened to this show
before we're not really great at this
and so no reason to be nervous at all so
what's up
um well yeah i've listened quite a bit
and you talk um you know pretty often
about when these hard things happen
about not trying to go back to the way
things were before
and trying to you know build something
new
and i'm just wondering exactly how do
you
how do you do that um so what happened
in your life
well our
um
our 16 year old
um son
um he's been hey hold on one second hold
on a second take a breath
be good
take a big deep breath and hold it and
just hang on to it for a second and then
let it out
you got a lot on your chest right
um
yeah it's been a
it's been
quite a few months yeah i'm so sorry so
what happened what's up
um
so
he
has been in a residential place for
about six weeks now
um
and he'll most likely be coming home
we're guessing in the next few weeks
okay
um
what was he in for what yeah what
happened
for all that um
short story we um ended up or i ended up
having to call
911 um the week after school
finished for them
um for him trying to to hurt himself
um
and it kind of been
coming to a head for the
the month before that and
um
so he was you know all that happened and
he was in the
uh psych room with the er for
for three nights and and that was tough
that's a scary place yeah yeah it's not
cool i've sat in those those many many
nights in those those rooms and they're
not great
i'm so sorry yeah
it's like a storage unit yeah and you
throw cover on top and all the
restrictions and everything it's a mess
man i'm so sorry yeah golly dude
um so yeah he'd been struggling with
swimming you know anxiety and depression
and and screens and
and all that kind of exploded during
covid with having they didn't go back to
school around here until
may
we were home
trying to do virtual school the whole
time
and anyway so we took him
straight from the hospital up
to
a residential place which has been you
know really it's been really good
um but so right now we're just trying to
navigate
when he comes home um
how do you
feel like you're not holding your breath
and yeah and turn those alarms off and
all the stuff get a chance to start over
so this is
man number one
like i'd say it 100 times um
i've i've
hugged a lot of moms in your situation
over the years and i i i'll say it one
more time but i'm so sorry
like nobody should see their
nobody have to call 9-1-1 on their own
kid
and or for their own kid and
the courage you took to try to not solve
that problem or to recognize as a mom
i'm over my head in this is
so profound and most moms and dads
who've never experienced what you
experienced don't know what it's like to
have to
hold that tension right i want to take
care of my kid and realize i can't
and calling in other people to come help
your kid that's a huge thing and so high
five to you good for you
um and my guess
you alluded to it a little bit but
you've been worried about this kid for a
long long time right so this has been
you've been slowly drowning for the last
probably six or seven months and then
you end up with a 911 call and then in a
trauma er psychiatric er which is a
nightmare and
you've been going through this too right
oh yeah we all have yeah it's a whole
family
yeah but you're i'm only talking to you
and so i want to acknowledge this is
hard and this has been hard hard season
and um
man i hate that for you yeah so the
other side of this call is is um which i
love is you saying all right you have
all these little cute slogans deloney
how do i actually do this crap in my
house
right like oh cute little metaphor
i i need this is real for me so i love
this um so i appreciate the call here
um so backing out of this thing
um how long have you known your son's
not okay
um
he's got we have four other kids and
he's kind of always been his own
person yeah super wanting his
independence and has his own ideas and
you know that's been him since he was
little okay um but i say i would say
that
this really started you know showing up
um
just this last fall okay you know for
backing up close enough
um
i'd say you know october november-ish
yeah um when it really started kind of
building up he
he was doing fine with online school and
then
you know eventually things
he would sleep in and miss a class and
that would make it hard to go back to
class and
and then he'd get behind on an
assignment so we wouldn't go to class
and then he tried to go you know just
yeah just snowballs
yeah
was there something that set this off or
was it just the gradual disconnect from
his community that
spun it out or
and or let me ask you that was there
also were you and your husband or you
and whoever's there trying to
figure out how to work from home was
there more chaos than normal or was it
just him slowly unplugging from
everything
um
well five kids at home trying to do
online school at the same time
you know that's not chaos i meant
something else yeah of course right
cheers
he's a pretty social kid and i think
just the whole
disconnect from from everything and on
top of
you know mom and dad saying get off
youtube you're supposed to be in class
and
and
i just
kind of built and built he kind of he
let us know that he'd been struggling
with you know some pornography things
and to me that's kind of where it
started it kind of went from downhill
from there real quick
just
everything
so when you call when you called 9-1-1
um walk me through that's that scene
um
well we
the rest of us were heading out of town
to go see grandma for the week and
he didn't want to come
and so he was going to be here
my husband was staying here also but at
work um
he wanted
me to leave you know the computer the
internet and just let him have
access to it you know the whole time
they were gone and
and
we told him that he could have it when
his dad got home
in the evenings and this this had built
you know the course of technology stuff
was huge for him
and so that was not okay we you know he
was hiding everything he could think of
to keep us from going he took our keys
and our wallets and our
shoes and you know the
work badge and and was hiding everything
so that we wouldn't leave
um
and we pretty much had to you know push
our way out of the house
to leave that morning
and it was
what was he scared of my husband
um
probably he hates
that it's wasted time that he could be
doing stuff and that he's not you know
connected to
he doesn't have a phone
we haven't done that yet with him and so
so does he have any of that connection
and number one good for you
um was he
not wanting y'all to leave because y'all
are his lifeline he's connected to you
all or he'd not want y'all to leave
because when you all left the internet
went off
that's
number two okay okay
pretty much okay i invited him to come i
said come and you can use the computer
at grandma's house and i don't think he
wanted to face you know
grandma he kind of avoids anybody right
now who would come to the house he would
he would take off and
you know leave until they were gone
so now that he normally doesn't have a
problem with grandma
now that
yeah and that's the demon of um
depression right is yeah this pain is
innately my fault all of it
and
it's never gonna go away and then other
people become a threat right and
the and so does sunlight and so does
movement instead of going outside and so
does disconnecting from the computer or
whatever your addictions are and
um so it's this weird self-reinforcing
um and the only way i can describe it
is yeah unless you you may have
experienced it but it's like having a
weight tied to your leg and you're in
the water and it's just pulling you
under and you know all i have to do is
pull my foot out of this thing and yeah
feel like you can't
and it just slowly pulls you under
um yeah so
you said he's been doing good so how's
his time
in
in the the treatment center been
um
is he allowed to talk to you guys did
disconnect from you guys have you
written your letters phone calls how's
that been
he can call um every day if he wants to
he hasn't chosen to call at all yet he
says he's using his time to call
another friend that had been there and
had left and he was talking to him which
you know is fine yeah hold on stop right
there that hurts
it's not not fine that's that's that's
hard
right
yeah yeah
don't just blow over that
because the greatest thing on the the
the
the dressing for your wound right now
would be if he called you and said hey i
love you guys and i'm okay and i'm gonna
be coming home soon i can't wait to see
y'all and he's not
yeah every day y'all are waiting for
that call and it's not coming right
yeah his siblings three of them have had
birthdays you know while he's been gone
and they thought
give him a call
and
anyway
i mean not anyway yeah
it stinks have you and your family sat
down and owned that
um well we have been able to do
um family sessions over zoom with him
now okay so we've gotten to see him no
but i mean i think it's worthy to
acknowledge
he's been sick he's not been doing well
and we all hoped he would call and he
didn't and it's okay to be heartbroken
about that
yeah otherwise there's going to be some
built-in resentment when he comes home
it will turn into at some point why
didn't you
right yeah and i think it's good to own
that just eat whether even if it's just
you and his dad or you and the older kid
i don't know whoever's been struggling
with that but how's the zoom sessions
been
um they're up and down
is he got a lot of anger
um
yeah when we started he definitely did
the therapist told us freno pretty much
just take it just listen
just try to validate and try to you know
just let him talk what was he mad about
um
that we were trying to keep him from
doing what he loved doing that we
weren't we were listening but not ever
understanding
um and what he loved doing was him
internet related
yeah you know playing games online with
his friends or making videos or
um he's very all his interests are
are a lot of them on on the computer
tech yeah
um and so when we said okay it's been
you know six hours time to take a break
it was
to him that was never enough time
so is the
over time
the anger's dissipated a little bit and
where is he at now
yeah
um you know we had a really a good
session with him and and then this last
one was a little discouraging because
we're working on this family agreement
what's it going to look like when
when he comes home and
we still just don't
completely agree there and he just you
could you could see
that he just shut down
after a while he just walked out and
um
so
you know that's discouraging it feels
like those are the discussions we had at
home
and where we'd hit that wall and there
was just
no
we didn't know what to do after that
you're right back where you started
that's kind of where we're at
yeah what's the therapist saying to you
guys
um
he's trying really hard to keep matt's
trust or keep our son's trust
um
and
so
you know a lot of it is
it is trying to
understand what he's saying
um
and not necessarily
you know
to our son it's if it's you understand
me so that means give me what i'm asking
i can do whatever i want yes
uh-huh yes and if you don't do that then
you're rejecting not just what i want
but you're rejecting me as a person
right
and
and you know that's inaccurate right
yeah okay and is the therapist
validating that's inaccurate too
he's letting our son you know feel that
at least
he's letting him
because that's what he does feel that
mom and dad
you know don't understand and it feels
to him like we're rejecting him so he's
letting that sit so
it is important and i would press the
therapist if y'all have private time
with the therapist it is important to
let those feelings be felt it is
and
the therapist a good therapist is also a
teacher
and for a
fully limbic 16 year old with an with a
barely
forming um
prefrontal cortex
it's important to help them okay you
feel this now let's back out and pull
this apart and see what it is accurate
what if it is not
yeah and i think a lot of that happens
behind the scenes where we aren't there
okay okay we do all sorts of therapy and
group stuff
i just want to make sure that's
happening because yeah there's got the
as this thing transitions to him coming
home
the therapist plays a key role in
helping
you should hear things like yes you feel
like they are rejecting you
but you know that is not accurate
correct we talked about this yes you
should hear things like that
yeah
and at some point the counselor can't
just sit there and validate feeling
after feeling after feeling right
um now
he may tell you we ha we're not there
yet the kid is still so hyper-sensitive
and is still in danger of hurting
himself again that we're not there yet
and i trust their expertise obviously
so to back out and ask your question
have y'all got a release date
um
not yet insurance kind of goes a couple
weeks at a time um it doesn't sound like
y'all are there yet it doesn't sound
like you may be a ways away
i'm guessing we're at least a couple
weeks okay away if not more okay
so here's a couple of things
you said two things already which i
think are really good which are
you and with the therapist and your son
and your family are working on a
home agreement here's what this is going
to look like and what that becomes is an
external document an external set of
agreement that you can point to so that
it doesn't become personal
it's not y'all hate me it is nope we all
look over here we agreed on this right
and we agreed on this amount of time i
am 1 000 so i want you to take computer
six hours of computer time it away and
put cocaine in there put alcohol in
there
you got your instincts are right
your heart about dude this just doesn't
feel like this is good for him is right
all right and there's a difference
between hey i'm really good at coding or
i really love making videos oh that's
awesome
but video prep comes with storyboarding
and going outside and shooting videos
only a chunk of it is cutting and
editing the video right
and so there's all kinds of
po all kind of stuff you do pre and
actual shoot that doesn't involve
sitting for a screen all day there is a
heavy editing part all that to say is
your heart and soul is right there
and i would not especially in
partnership with the therapist i would
not budge on your family values when it
comes to that okay and that's me just
talking parent to parent i would be in
the exact same boat with you
there has to be an ability to pull help
the 16 year old pull those feelings back
from i know i feel like y'all are taking
this from me and that means you're
rejecting me i know my parents love me
and i've seen countless 16 17 18 year
olds get there okay
um
he just may not be there yet he may
still be really hurting and really
struggling
um
yeah
so here's a couple of things i'll just
toss out there
that i think you and your other four
kids and your
your are y'all married
yeah dad lived at home okay that y'all
can begin to work on now okay
number one is creating and i'm not
saying this doesn't happen okay you may
say we already have that
but there's this is just for anyone
listening to this is you've got to
create a state safe and stable home
and i know that's hard and it sounds
like it's an accusation it's not it's
just saying hey make sure this is in
place a lot of that stability comes from
you and your husband making sure y'all
are okay
both your marriage is good your mental
health is good your physical health is
good you are taking care of yourselves
and you create a
a platform of stability that starts from
top down
you all have morning routines you all
have got prayer life y'all got y'all are
living into your values does that make
sense
yep absolutely okay so where do you
where do you rank on that how are y'all
um
right now it's it's good and i feel bad
saying that sometimes because don't ever
apologize for that that's great
yeah it feels peaceful um awesome no
we've definitely gone through
you know marriage stuff where
it's been it's been rough on it um
and we've had to be very
vulnerable very open with each other and
um and really try hard to not let that
fall apart and it's gotten stronger and
better and i have a saint of a husband
and he's got a saint of a wife right so
that's how those things work together
that's awesome okay so the second thing
here is
create a life
of um
active participation outside of the
screens
and what i mean by that is y'all may
already have this okay last night um we
went out and played this weird game of
tag slash wrestling slash all of a
sudden my kid one of my kids turned into
a cat in the yard and now granted we've
got a big field out in front of our
house and but it was the weirdest game
of tag wrestle thing i don't even know
what ended up with uh swinging each
other around like helicopters but all i
like to say is
i hear a lot of parents say get off the
screens turn that computer off and then
there's no other connective option for
their kids
and so
it
unfortunately and fortunately it's up to
you and dad to create
outdoor
indoor whatever alternatives to those
screens which means i got to put my
phone down which sometimes annoying i
got a looming book deadline which i
couldn't work on and i couldn't start it
until nine o'clock last night
um but because i gotta i've got to
provide them that connection right i
can't just dump them off to the
neighborhood kids i can't i've got to be
active there so i think that's something
if y'all don't have already you may
order me a babe maybe a super active
family i'll take walks every night after
dinner y'all kick the soccer ball around
you play catch whatever those things are
but that you guys develop a culture that
he may be surprised to come home to
um a third thing is that he when he does
come home does not become the house
mascot
okay
he's got to feel like a valued member of
the home and that means with
responsibilities and boundaries and
that's one of the hardest things i've
experienced with parents when a kid
comes home is they want they want to
velvet glove the whole thing
which
then
it's like putting on velvet gloves and
all he needs is touch and boundaries and
velvet gloves feel like the right thing
to do like i don't want to do the thing
that's going to send him back to that
thing
and then that reinforces a disconnection
that reinforces he's not safe and then
he goes back to the thing does that make
sense
yeah or i hear parents do the opposite
they create these crazy rigid boundaries
that are insane
and then that sends so it's it's this
balancing act i wish i could tell you
here you know that analogy i've used
about excavating and rebuilding a new
building every family
new building is going to look different
and you're going to have different
architects and different engineers for
where you live what your cultural values
are if you've got spiritual advice but
those are it's all going to look
different
as much as you can include him in that
and hold him responsible for and
accountable to his part in that does
that make sense but there's got to be
he's got to feel like i've got a role in
this family
as annoying as that is
now he's the best brother like through
all this
he's had a great relationship with his
siblings it's mom and dad that you know
have the problem awesome he's a
wonderful he'll go out and play with him
he's great with him oh it's so good i
want you all to start going out and play
with it up too
yeah okay um the number number four here
is having a safety plan making sure
you've got a plan for
who to call when to call that the kids
know who to call right everybody's on
the same page about that and that he
knows the safety plan too it's not
something you hide from him and then you
get an integrated plan with the school
counselor with his psychologist and his
psychiatrist i'm sure
from the treatment center like whenever
you have an outpatient treatment center
he needs to know that all the adults in
his life are talking
there is no hey don't tell this don't
tell it
everybody's on the same page here with
one goal and that's making sure you're
okay
and he may fight that you guys don't
trust me you know what
no it's way deeper than that man we love
you yeah and when you're now you're
playing a long game he'll get that when
he's 25 he won't get that as a 16 year
old there's a reason 16 year olds aren't
allowed to buy
aren't allowed to buy uh alcohol or weed
or guns right because we've all as a
society agreed ah their heads aren't
totally there
and if you've ever driven with 16 year
olds you know that we probably shouldn't
be driving they shouldn't be driving
either right
um yeah and then the biggest one at the
end is that strange bizarre as much as
you can get away with
um
daily skin on skin contact with mom and
with dad
and the number of dads that i've met
with and seen over the years that have
never front hugged their sons
that don't have a daily high-touch
interaction with their sons
is
alarming and heartbreaking
every dad should touch their sons on the
face on the arms hug their sons every
single day of their life
and that's not a non-masculine thing to
do
that's not a who you
no dude you have to it stabilizes their
brain chemistry
and
shockingly it helps dad too
but moms need to do that and once once
kids get to be 14 15 16 and they got
hairy legs and they smell like crap and
they're just like you know they just
become like hairy mops in the house
they're just like oh gross
um
parents have to lean into that
and so what i would love you all to
start saying now on the front end do it
with all of your kids
this is hug time they'll i've heard
stories of parents like lining them up
um they line them up and they nope i'm
touching everybody's face i'm gonna kiss
you on the forehead every one of you and
it's an 18 year old basically a grown
man that's old enough to go to war and
or to get drafted at least and he's like
come on mom it's like nope
we're hugging and they probably love it
well it's a drama thing and i had one
counselor tell me like well you know
you're really taking away their autonomy
fair that's fair um and my daughter i'm
a little more sensitive to when she says
daddy please don't i'm trying to teach
her to have autonomy of her young
five-year-old body and so i don't
actually when she says please don't but
um
my son has come to crave it you know
what i mean and he's as masculine and
goofbally as they come
and he craves it and so what i would
tell you guys is
change that in your home is that
something you all do regularly or no
um better with the younger kids okay
there you go so reintegrate that
if
it i mean again if he comes home he's uh
he needs to be um
have autonomy in his body
of his body and you can't force yourself
like no you will let me you're right but
um yeah i don't see that with a lot of
kids that they reject it they may like
and do how kids roll their eyes but
um
a morning when he's come stumbling down
and then an evening comes stumbling down
um
it can be magical and then he's going to
watch you guys do y'all watch are you
all on your phones a lot on your ipads a
lot you all work on your computers a lot
you watch a lot of tv or movies there's
some of that becomes just environmental
and how he picks that stuff up
so um one last thing one last last thing
i would love for there to be some sort
of shared journal that you all have
that you can go by it's just a lined
journal it's a like one of those that
looks like a book it's hard back
where y'all can write your feelings your
thoughts back and forth to each other
that this is an ongoing dialogue that
y'all are learning to communicate again
together
and
face face-to-face contact can be really
hard it can set off all kinds of
trauma alarms in a kid's brain or it can
it can feel fearful especially with the
power dynamic between a kid and their
parents especially if he has turned you
guys into the bad guys for the time
being that won't last forever by the way
but right now he may have put you there
so
having an ongoing dialogue and you may
get up and he's written nothing or he
may write y'all suck or i hate
everything whatever
him getting to read
i love you guys and y'all could just
pass it back and forth to each other
um
you write in it and you put on his bed
he writes in it and drops it off or he
throws it in the floor or whatever y'all
are going in there and picking it up
and writing in it we're so grateful that
you're our son so glad you're here you
are the best little brother i'm best big
brother we've ever seen
hey thanks for and what you're doing is
you're just opening a dialogue in
something about writing it is just
different but you'll look back hopefully
in five years ten years and you'll have
a book here of letters that y'all wrote
back and forth to each other and
hopefully that dialogue begins to shift
y'all are gonna have to get some thick
skin so i'd recommend you and your
husband go see somebody make sure you
all got um a pastor a counselor in your
life that you trust that you can lean
into but um
that would be a way to create an ongoing
dialogue back and forth it doesn't
involve screens it doesn't involve eye
contact that he may not be ready for
that y'all may not be ready for right
but it's just a way to re-engage each
other so those are my ideas keep that
keep this clip and y'all can work
through it as a family if you've got i
don't know
if you got kids 11 12 or older i don't i
think it's smart for them to hear this
to think through hey we're going to love
our little brother and he's going to
have chores like everybody's got
responsibilities like everybody and he's
going to keep loving you like everybody
and we're going to start going out and
playing outside after dinner every
evening or a couple three or four
evenings a week or whatever that looks
like and you're going to get to recreate
what home looks like for you guys so
take these not as dogma but as just
guiding principles just a way to think
through it and thank you for asking okay
cute deloney you always tell us to
excavate what does that even
mean
ah
we'll be thinking about you lynn thank
you so so so much for your call
all right let's go to sarah in kansas
city sarah hey what's going on
hey how are you i am rocking onto the
brick of dawn how about you
doing good awesome so what's up
okay so i wrote it down so i could be
direct
um
so i am one of three sisters um
short story like we were homeschooled
elementary
uh my dad was a pastor when we were
younger so we grew up in the church okay
and right now we're trying to deal with
my parents
basically was it a good grow up in the
church experience sometimes that means
one of two things like it was great or
we're dealing with all kinds of family
trauma
yeah not great
[Laughter]
it was awful um okay so
great him i don't want to like
completely put it down
hey as a good preacher's kid you're able
to loop it around and make it sort of
your fault but they were great
they just hit us with sticks a couple of
times a week it wasn't okay good job way
to go so we'll get that's a whole other
call someday i think so um talk to me
about your three sisters and you're
dealing with your parents so what's up
um so basically like especially with
kovid
it's just hard to communicate because
when we do try to communicate with them
like our concerns
it
comes back it's the end of days it's
i get a bible verse i get a dream i get
a prophecy you know what i mean sweet
where's just like
and that's kind of how it's always been
to a point good so it's like
and just to put it out there my oldest
sister is in healthcare i mean both of
them are i'm in the restaurant industry
so we see things like first hand correct
where they're in a small town
have no diversity
you know
so there's just a way that
they see what they see on the internet
and in their small community y'all are
seeing things on the front lines
and
like literally my sister is intubating
people okay so there's a um like an
experiential component to this and then
there is mom and dad just being mom and
dad and now they've gone into end times
realms is that fair yes
okay and so how how can i help you you
ask me what what do y'all do
so basically
like my sister tried to like have a good
discussion but it just ends up blowing
up of course and i always just avoid the
conflict
okay but it's you know like
are you supposed to
like dive in or do you just dance around
it and talk about the weather yes
okay so
the way i deal with these kind of
conversations is i wait to be invited in
which i never am
and
or i that's not true i am invited in for
a living but with my close friends and
family they know how i think about
things and i know how they think about
things and so
um
the only thing you can do is either a
completely avoid them draw boundaries
and say we i refuse to have this
conversation with you
b um
or yeah number two you can
just try to connect
meaning i know what i'm gonna get with
this this and this and i'm gonna still
go have a cup of coffee anyway
i'm gonna still
take mom out for dinner or whatever
not with the goal of trying to convert
anybody or try to win anybody but just
try to
be connected that's it i mean you can't
change their mind they've been this way
for their your whole life
yeah right and then you throw
um
end times
that's the college i mean you throw that
i mean
there's nothing you can do to change
anybody's mind here the question you
have to have is
is it hurting you to be in their
presence and if it is you have to make a
decision on what your boundaries are
going to be there or
are you just going to wade into it and
love mom and dad and roll your eyes and
go about your day
and i think that's hard i mean that's
kind of what i was thinking
but it's hard to because we all live far
away that's right that's right you can't
just go have coffee or you know what i
mean
yeah yeah and
and at some point you have to decide if
they don't want to talk to you
um if they don't want to connect with
you you're going to have to decide to
grieve that because that really hurts
and at some point there's still that
magical fairyland thinking that they're
gonna one day go you know what we're so
your childhood we're sorry for that you
know what like um we've got different
opinions now and we read this article
and holy smokes were we off right and at
some point the three sisters y'all have
to come to the terms that's never going
to happen
yeah
and that is a hard
gut-wrenching tearful
realization
and this is another question i have too
is
so
you know like my dad's great
but like my mom she she wants more
out of our relationship yeah you know
but she's very loyal to my dad so it's
kind of like
i feel like she's asking for more
yeah the hard part here is she's a
grown-up and she can get more if she
wants it
yeah she wants you to give more
not her
and so she's asking you to carry the
bulk of this relationship and that is an
unfair request from a parent to their
child
okay
um you can though say i would love to
start
communicating more i can't have the cove
conversation anymore
and i love hearing about your faith
journey mom i don't want to hear any
more about end times
and i think that's a we did that this
year for my family and then my family is
all a bunch of nerds my family's all way
smarter than me and
um we're all
you can't ima i'm the quiet one at the
dinner table but that way and we should
tell you how our how fun and exciting
our thanksgivings and christmases are
they're hilarious we laugh we get all
loud with each other um but there's a
bunch of really smart people sitting
around our table and
um we sent mike my we sent an email this
year no politics and because you know in
december and november was right before
the election no politics and no no covey
talk
and we just sent that out and everybody
in our family abided by it was awesome
but we just called it out
now i've got really extraordinary
parents i got really extraordinary
in-laws i'll i will say that because i
know there are some of my friends who
did that their parents would be like oh
you can't tell me what to talk about but
we just said hey let's don't do that and
all everybody was
great and so it's just kind of saying
hey that's gonna be our boundary i don't
want my kids listening to us fighting i
don't want all these crazy arguments i
don't want to be scrolling the internets
trying to come up with arguments let's
just hang out
right just go fishing or go for a walk
can we just like do that can we talk
about the weather can we talk about
boyfriends and husbands and weird
girlfriends you know and can we just do
that tell old stories we play games and
that's where we focused on and ended up
being
really great trips all around
so i need to find more games
i mean i don't know what works in your
phrase is my go-to i don't know yes come
up with a different game y'all can do
better than that um we did something to
sil and we got grandkids so it makes it
easier right but we did something as
silly as um zoom charades which were oh
my parents were all in it was a riot
dude hey i mean i like we laughed so
hard watching my parents they were in
separate rooms on different computers
doing it was a riot my kids were dying
left all of us were having a blast
um we did all kinds of things like that
and um
we all want another thing hey this is a
great idea is to read a book together
all four of you your sisters and your
mom that's just fiction
there's my wife has a like a text list
with her mom and some of the cousins of
her cousins and they just read like
fiction books and it's a blast they are
loving it everyone recommends something
but it's something that not political
not non not
you know it's just like a book right
it's like a fun book and they are loving
it and then i'm gonna start that with my
dad like we're gonna so there's all
kinds of things like that you can do
that's just being creative saying how
can we connect or we're going to all
listen to this one cd because you know
where it's 1844 or an old record or
whatever and then we're going to say
we're going to all get on a call and see
if we liked it or not but it's you being
creative saying i'm going to reconnect
this way but i think it starts with you
having a boundary saying hey i want to
reconnect with you so much mom
but we're not talking about these things
when it hurts my heart hurts your heart
we're gonna agree to not do that so
let's start talking about books and
music i got a great new book let's all
read it
i'll even buy the first one and mail it
out to all three of my sisters and to
you and we'll start there right so yes
you getting creative going that away um
and lean into it man but it's not your
job to carry that friendship in that
relationship
she's a grown adult too right
thank you so so much for that call i
know there are millions of people going
through that challenge
uh but
you can't change your mind
you can't heal her you can't tell her
that one thing and she's gonna go oh
yeah you can just love her
warts and all right all right stay tuned
we'll be right back on the dr john
dolone show
you always hear me talking about how
good deep sleep impacts your anxiety
your depression your attitude your
mental health your physical health your
work performance sleep is critical to
every single thing in your life and if
you want to change the way you sleep you
first start with a world class mattress
one that you can actually afford and you
know i only recommend things that me and
my family use in our home and that's why
i partnered with dream cloud mattress
dream cloud gives you premium
world-class materials in a mattress at
half the price they utilize innovative
sleep signs to build mattresses that
keep you cool that support you in any
position and it adapts to your body i
made sure they have price points for
every budget dream cloud is for you they
are currently running their biggest
offer ever a total of 650 bucks in
bedding and cash savings exclusive for
dr john dolone's show listeners they
also have a 365 day home trial sleep on
it for a year if you don't like it send
it back visit dreamcloudsleep.com
get 650 in savings and goodies and start
sleeping today
all right hey what's up we're back
listen i got i should listen again
that's five dollars to kelly you're
gonna get rich over there you can buy
your new minivan haven't seen any of it
yet
that's a fair statement that's a fair
statement
i would say i owe you but i work for
dave ramsey so i can't say that so i
should just whatever so i got this um
direct message on the instagrams and it
says this
dr d my 13 year old daughter will be
going back to class in school mid-august
um last year she was online all year
she's dealing with social anxiety and
depression how can i help her other than
getting a counselor which she already
has how can i as a mother support her i
feel helpless
she has no friends today in her session
she just cried for 15 minutes when i
asked her what happened she said all i
was doing was practicing how to get to
know someone so when i go back to school
i can hang out
but i couldn't do it i had a panic
attack any tips will help i'm so
grateful for this question i'm getting
this all over the place listen
there will be no easy way back for
millions and millions and millions of
kids going to school
getting out um
this idea this is going to be easy is
there going to be three steps or five
step process there won't be it'll be
hard
um and now with uh looks like the delta
variants on there's other schools
talking about going back online just to
start the school it's we're just going
to keep figuring this out
so here's a couple of things that you
can do in i don't have any notes here
this is just what i'm doing in my house
okay um so this is coming from
my head my heart not from some
like
four tips to you know lose weight and be
a better not that this is just what i'm
doing in my house
um step number one you've heard me say
this over and over i'm gonna keep going
back and keep going back to it skin on
skin contact with your kids every single
day
from you that means you start every day
with a hug that means you um when they
get home from school you hold their hand
you hold their face you look them in the
eyes you tell them that you love them
you're glad to see them
um you don't just in your rear view
mirror when you're driving them go hey
how was it fine
cool
and you just go back you you have to
stop you have to bridge that awkward gap
between you and your five-year-old you
and your 13 year old you and your 19
year old whatever
touch their body
if they're okay with it
look them in the eye and say i'm so glad
that you're my kid
i know it's so bananas going back to
school and i'm in your corner and i'm so
glad
number two you guys have to go move your
bodies together that means you're gonna
have to go outside and kick a soccer
ball around you're gonna have to not
just have a family movie now you have to
go family walk night
we're gonna do this together um if
you've got special needs kids if you've
got kids just wanna sit at home you're
going to have to figure that out
that could be as easy as we're just
going to go sit on the porch together
and i i don't know we're going to roll a
ball back i don't know what to make this
weird in that last call i just talked
about
we played the strangest game of tag
wrestle one of my kids started acting
like a cat and then we ended up swinging
each other i mean it was just
bongo for a while but we all got
sunshine none of us were wearing shoes
we got to contact the ground and um
we all got to laugh and we all got to
move our bodies around i also know that
i'm highly privileged living on a couple
of acres out in the woods
and if you're living in an apartment
downtown somewhere it's not so easy i
get that you got to figure it out you
got to get outside and you got to move
your body even if that's stopping on the
way home from picking your kids up from
school or when they get off the bus
you'll go to a local park i don't care
what it is you got to figure out a
couple days a week at least getting out
and moving your body together the third
thing is
as safely as possible and as often as
possible you've got to have other kids
around your kid
whether that's a church group whether
that's a hey we're just going to invite
four people over this is one of those
bring them over to watch a movie and eat
garbage i don't care they've got to be
in proximity to other kids
um so if you need to have pizza night
and come on overnight do it right if you
need to go buy a
um
we bought this little there it's like 10
bucks on amazon and it's a it
stretches out and you attach it and it's
a ping pong table that we just put over
our dining room table in the middle of
our living room like where our dining
table is
we just got people over like the
aesthetics of the living room i don't
care anymore the kids are in a crisis
and so we're gonna play ping-pong on our
kitchen table and we're gonna eat on our
front porch that's what we've been doing
um does it look great nope is it gonna
scratch my table up yup it is
are my kids gonna have memories of us
figuring it out along the way yes are we
going to do i get to smash a ping pong
ball at my kids and it makes me feel a
little bit better yes right um but we're
going to figure those things out
and it could be puzzles on the middle of
the kitchen of the dining room table it
could be hey we're going to play games
every night we're gonna these cards that
i'm sending out to you guys um that are
gonna be available to buy here in a
month or two um the whatever it is we're
gonna have direct connection with their
kids they're we're gonna have kids at
our house if we at all possible or i'm
gonna have my kid they're gonna be able
to go to people's houses we can do that
safely
if you can't do it safely then we're
gonna go to parks we're gonna meet
places we're gonna do whatever and this
is what it's gonna cut into guys it's
gonna cut into our tv watching time
it's gonna cut into an hour or two of
our sleep my i'm tracking my sleep
really closely i've got this with this
whoop strap thing here
my sleep is it's getting nod off right
i'm having to make other adjustments i'm
having to work out a little bit
different i'm having to change my diet
i'm having to be highly intentional
because i'm getting less sleep because
i've got to put more of my focus on
connecting with my kids in the mornings
and in the evenings
and
they're fraying at the edges not just my
kids all of our kids
and then the fourth thing is
like i love this like we got a counselor
here what she said is so true
we're practicing reentry
it's this could be one of the great
moments in history where we teach our
kids that relationship is something you
practice connection is something you
practice
so if you have a kid who's stressed out
practice hey what's it going to look
like when you go back
practice being silly practice saying i
don't like your dress
and
what is it what's a good response
start practicing relationships with your
kids and by the way those of you going
back to work
same thing
those of you who are been working from
home and you're dying on the vine here
and you're going to start going back two
days a week or three days a week and
then they're going to come home and go
back
you too because you got to practice
relationships too so this is going to
help you at your work environment as
well
your work environment as well but your
kids need right now is you to lean in
and you two figure out ways with even if
it's like hey you know what we're gonna
we're gonna start we're gonna play fall
soccer this year we're not even a soccer
family we're doing it now
we
we're playing softball or baseball or
whatever the thing is we're having
saturday hike day let your yard grow a
little bit taller right i don't whatever
your thing is it's time to start getting
super creative
connection outside
and making sure you are touching and
interacting with your kids on a daily
regular basis and all that said
it's still going to be hard
some kids are going to really struggle
some kids are going to just zoom right
back into this no pun intended they're
going to get right back into it and
they're not going to miss a beat it's
going to be hard for everybody be really
gracious with yourself with your kids
stay connected to their teachers make
sure you've got a bunch of other adult
eyes looking on them if you can
do the best you can but lean into
connection thank you so much for that
instagram man that's good um all right
as we wrap up today's show man the
greatest song
of all time of all time before
not the trumpet you're gonna do but
um
not to trigger you with a wilco lyric
but in light of one of the calls there's
a great wilko song called
uh what's the name of it
you never know it has a line in it every
generation thinks it's the last thinks
it's the end of the world
so that was a pretty good philosophical
line there's wilco being philosophical
so what's the line
every generation thinks it's the end of
the world it's kind of like every new
generation is like oh this is the this
is it man this is it yeah yeah
well i've got to carry on i've got even
better one
i think it's uh is it off
i don't know what record it's off of
but it's an old classic it doesn't even
matter what record it's off of it's that
good
it's by michael stipe and the guys
r.e.m
the boys
wrote their classic
that i guess wilco pilfered a line from
it's the end of the world as we know it
and it goes something like this
that's great starts with an earthquake
birds and snakes an aeroplane
and lenny bruce is not afraid it's eye
of a hurricane listen to yourself churn
the world serves its own needs don't
miss serve your own needs speed it up a
notch speed grunt no strength the ladder
starts to clatter with fear of height
down height wire in
a fire representing seven games in a
government for hire and a combat site
left of west and coming in a hurry with
the furies breathing down your neck and
then
team by team reporters baffled right
trump tethered cr whoa
dude rem calling it back in the day crop
look at the low plain fine then uh oh
overflow population common food but
it'll do save yourself serve yourself
you're vitriolic patriotic slam fight
bright light feeling pretty psyched
right
it's the end of the world as we know it
it's it's the
end of the world as we know it
we have to sing this it's the end of the
world as we
[Music]
we we literally have the greatest show
on on radio on podca on the internets
do you all feel fine
[Music]
i don't feel very fine about my singing
on that one but overall your singing was
not great but we got hit by a box today
and you're still fine
and listeners y'all are fine youtube
watchers y'all are fine and this has
been the dr john dolone show